[Music]
from the pagodas of myanmar to the high
rises of singapore from what were the
killing fields of cambodia to the
pulsating heart of jakarta 640 million
people you have 300 million muslims 120
million christians 150 million buddhists
tawis confucianists
thailand malaysia the philippines and
vietnam asean is one of the world's most
complex regions
we have such huge
and such ability now to create business
asean has a combined economy the size of
indians the opportunities are massive
but so are the challenges
the importance of borders particularly
in our regions
is fading away
southeast asia is a region at the
crossroads an emerging economic
powerhouse whose future depends on how
it moves forward key decisions made now
will affect asean the next generation
[Applause]
hello i'm hazlinda ahman we begin here
in thailand where a little over 50 years
ago asean was born five countries that
came together fearful of the advance of
communist china
a lot has changed since then
vietnam myanmar and cambodia have joined
from difficult times and the region's
economies have been growing on average
at more than five percent a year every
year for the past 10 years its biggest
achievement
is to take the most diverse corner of
planet earth okay
where are the
million people you have 300 million
muslims uh
120 million christians 150 million
buddhists
taoist confucianists
and in the most improbable region of
planet earth
you produce peace and prosperity
[Music]
we have moved a long long way and i'm
continuing to be very optimistic of
course
there's always the doom say that asean
hasn't moved i think it hasn't gone
further enough
but
look at airasia look at the
inter asean travel the inter asean
commerce that goes in our cargo
shows that we have
moved a long way and i remain very very
optimistic about lsu different countries
have different stage of financial sector
development so it is up to the context
of each country but
standardization might be needed to
promote cross-border
financial integration within us and it's
not so much of standardization having
one house in standards but i think
making sure that domestic standard of
each country is in interoperable
particularly when we talk about
cross-border payment activities
this is the golden triangle
i'm in thailand
that's myanmar and that's laowas the
river the mighty nikon which flows all
the way to vietnam this area infamous
for its opium trade is just one small
piece of the jigsaw that is asean
the 10-member block is made up of vastly
different nations from indonesia with
the world's biggest muslim population
to tiny brunei each with diverse
politics rules and religion
asean's 640 million people account for
around 9
of the world's population and its
combined gdp of around 2.8 trillion
dollars puts asean on the same level as
the uk france and india
we have countries that are exceptionally
rich
like singapore and brunei and you have
countries that are quite poor like laos
and cambodia they belong to the same
organization you have countries that are
incredibly big like indonesia
with 270 million people
in singapore with 5 million people
but that's that creates a certain degree
of complementarity
among the asean countries
the cost of moving goods via customs to
speed the single window hasn't come to
complete fruition yet
and asean has to sort itself out there
quickly
otherwise the likes of china and india
will dominate e-commerce will dominate
trade flows is there a sense that asean
nations are competing against each other
more than they're cooperating i i think
there's a that's a that's a real
question and that's that's a real the
real answer is yes
um
and but you see it in china a little bit
as well you you get one
province trying to compete with another
right that rivalry exists obviously in
asean it's national so it's a little bit
more
one of the key milestones of the group
has been the creation of the asean
economic community set up in 2015 the
aec's end goal is to create a single
market which is fully integrated into
the global economy
for trading goods it is
effectively a single market and
what we need to work on further is that
there are still some areas of
non-terrible barriers which need to be
managed
but
i've been working on the aec for many
many years
for at least 20 years
when we were negotiating the details of
this agreement
and when i look back over this 20 years
i must say that i'm quite pleased with
what it has achieved
it's a it's always a question of whether
you regard it as a
cup huffle cup half empty
and i would say that it's more than half
full
from where we started i'd like to see a
common market
i would love to see freedom of movement
of labor that might be
a step too far in 10 years
but if i can get a common market if i
get common ownership you know why can't
airasia 100 of all our airlines in asia
rcn should benefit the citizens of
aseans
in various dimensions um you know
financial integration economic
integration trade integration
even to have a common
policies towards economic sustainability
um you know
the the importance of borders
particularly in our regions
is fading away
[Music]
at this time of year a huge haze
blankets large parts of northern
thailand myanmar and lars
farmers are burning off their fuels
clearing land after the harvest their
produce packed away in small rice meals
like these connecting smes to the fourth
industrial revolution is one of asean's
greatest challenges
the cost of
financial
services is coming down dramatically
with fintech and with the digital
technology
we are not only able to provide those
banking services insurance services to
many more people
but also to people in
remote areas because what what is
important now is to have a mobile a
smart mobile phone
and that is changing the shape of
financial services this is the secret
genius of asean
asean is the most imperfect organization
in the world in fact when you watch
asean in slow motion it takes two steps
forward one step backwards one step size
it's like a crap going around in circles
right but you slice asean decade by
decade it keeps growing stronger and
stronger and one of the reasons is that
asean is very flexible
so the consensus principle is a very
good principle to have because it's very
flexible
it's hard to believe that 440 million
people in asean do not have bank
accounts that's next as we continue to
explore asean the next generation
welcome back much of southeast asia has
been built on small businesses like
these in some economies smes account for
as much as 90 of the jobs but despite
that the number of unbanked remains huge
440
million people that's the combined
population of the us and germany put
together
people often talk about tapping the
unbanked but so far that's been quite
difficult in fact they've been targeting
mainly the underbanked what are the
challenges
that the different um dimensions um when
you talk about um typing and bank of
people who are underserved
we have to have a clear policy with
respect to the types of products and the
types of segments that we want to
promote
for instance
in in thailand we have had
very high household debt and it could be
certain segments of
the populations that are overly indebted
so we we need to promote fintech
together with responsible lending
policies to make sure that
they you know get better service at a
more reasonable cost using new
technology and not contributing to
to to more problems that would lead to
you know financial fragilities for them
i think the rating agency type
credit bureau
the credit guarantee program
as that resolution could also be ways
how to help support
access
financial access
to the sme
at the same time i think the digital
financial solutions could also be a way
for sme to have greater access
to the financial
pool
because the
better information accuracy so that
risks could be accessed different
countries have different stages of
financial inclusion
um
for thailand um the access to bank
deposit account is not low by by
emerging market standards but with more
concerns about
you know cross-border payment
transaction i mean the cost for
cross-border payment transactions
in and out of thailand is among the
highest in the world so we want to
address that and fintech can come in and
and you know providing new types of
technology cut out the middleman and
allowing new players to come into this
market
for the traders of myanmar to the rice
farmers of cambodia for businesses in
hanoi manila jakarta bangkok fintech is
forging a whole new future but the key
words keep coming back sustainability
connectivity and inclusion
how do you ensure that countries like
cambodia like vietnam are not left
behind
well first i'll say that vietnam has
made
tremendous progress
so uh we we we have this uh when we
launched the uh
inclusive growth program
the there was special consideration for
cambodia allows
and myanmar
to access infrastructure funding for
instance
at a battle rate
so those are practical initiatives that
we need to do there are also special
considerations in
for uh training and retraining of
workers
of providing technical and vocational
training
so
those are important practical measures
and because the cost structure of these
economies are still
lower than the other asean members
some investors do find them attractive
as a company airasia has embraced
digital with the onslaught of fourth
industrial revolution how prepared is
the region
for what's to come
well i think we're a bit behind but boy
we're catching up i mean if you look at
the
the fact that the tech unicorns in
indonesia or the usage or viber in
philippines or line in thailand and
their growing amount of e-commerce
and the growing amount of connectivity
through mobile phones and applications
is not far behind
the thing that i keep telling people is
you need scale
right you need scale
and so asean in the tech world needs to
have scale
i don't think we're far behind i think
education needs to catch up a bit i
think we need to re-skill people in that
human capital
but i've always been one that
asean adapts very quickly as soon as
they see the opportunity will adapt
but i think
we have an opportunity to leapfrog if we
can adapt a few things i think the
integration among the
neighboring among the asean members have
been very significant and that has been
possible with the aec
2015 and that has led to a significant
change in the gdp growth
from say
about 1200 u.s dollar per capita income
to decades ago now to about
4 300
yes dollar per capita income which is
quite significant
in terms of financial integration how
difficult is that given that the 10
member nations are all at different
stages of development
actually because of different stage of
development they are complementary to
each other in certain countries like
singapore malaysia thailand for example
we are in excess
and other countries are also in the
need of money so i think we can support
and
each other in that way complementary to
each other definitely fintech can
improve productivity um in you know
other asean countries
you know financial systems in aseans are
a big room for for improvement and
technology can play a big role
fintech can also help enhance financial
inclusion within the region because you
know the cost of servicing different
segments of the people will be coming
down substantially using fintech
so
10 nations different cultures languages
and religions all at different stages of
development but is there an asean
identity we'll explore that next in
asean the next generation
asean in its first 50 years
has been a government to government
project it's governments to government
cooperation
now we've got to create a greater sense
of ownership
of asean among the people of asia and
here i'm glad that the asean countries
have copied the european union practice
so when you go to london and you go to
any asean mission they have the national
flag and the asean flag
is there an asean identity and a lot of
people have interviewed have been pretty
divided and whether there is one no i
don't think there is and i'm i'm an
aseanist i've been promoting this word
why not for a long time well i think uh
what does asean mean
to the common man and that asean needs
to work harder at the brand and the
identity does asean affect the common
man
probably the common man of street sees
asean more as a threat than an
opportunity in terms of the asean
identity there's a lot of work that is
going on as well on
the social and cultural aspects that
runs in parallel with our effort at
financial integration economy
integration
but as
trade
and investments increase as
tourism increase i think we will see
a far better understanding and
appreciation of each other in asean kun
chatsuri is there an asean identity
in many sense yes we are 600 million
people with a diverse
language culture and identities
but on the other hand in general we are
relatively
easygoing people
and i think that's his advantage of how
we could work well together
it's not just identity mobility across
borders is one of asean's biggest
challenges
labor goods and the flow of money here
people come across the border from
myanmar every day to work and trade in
thailand but often in asean borders
represent barriers to business
we have for instance you know a more
than three million
my workers in thailand but it's very
costly for them to transfer money back
to myanmar we have a lot of
a lot of traders that do you know border
trades very expensive for them to
receive money and also to pay money to
countries in in along the border so you
know fintech can help and come in and
improve financial inclusion in this
aspect in in a big way one of the issues
is labor crossing borders
how do we resolve that issue how can we
have standardization that is sensitive
issue because
the free flow of a labor it is not on
the cards because you would you have
different levels of
readiness for that a greater exchange
of
people
at certain levels you know say certain
professionals for instance that is being
pursued the labor markets are
at different stages of development
across asean
and what is important is for us to focus
on how we can integrate the economy
through trading goods through services
through investments and
if we are able to
generate good growth across different
parts of asean
the
people in each country
will have
suitable jobs who have good jobs the
other thing that we we have we work with
central banks in the regions and have
seen
very good progress is on promotion of
usage of local currencies for trade and
investment
two years ago we started between bank of
thailand and banknotes around malaysia
to promote the use of thai bad and
malaysian drinking for trade and
investment activities
last year bank indonesia joined in so we
had a three party arrangement and this
will help you know
narrow down the the the foreign exchange
spread between the local currencies and
also provide choices for for for
business people in the region to
minimize their foreign exchange
rate depending on where you live in
asean the block's future looks very
different for the big companies and the
big cities is not only access across
asean borders but also to the global
market
for the tens of millions of small to
medium enterprises it's access to any
markets workers want to get work where
they can and parents want to educate
their children that's a reason asean is
known as one of the most diverse and
complex regions in the world
minnesota your vision of asean for the
future
well i think we hope that asean remains
you know a safe
prosperous and uh place
and for which
we we can each improve the you know
well-being of people living in asean
all this work that we are doing on
economic integration financial
integration
on
promoting fintech and so on
ultimately has one simple aim which is
to improve the well-being of our people
in asean
and with that i think we can maintain
peace and prosper peace and stability in
asean we contribute to
the global peace and prosperity i think
many respects that we are seeing in the
western countries we see more
in asean
with greater wealth generated
so there will be more
demand and diversity
greater segmentation and certain
areas like the wealth management
probably will increasingly be
significant and important i think asean
should realize within itself what are
the strengths and what are the
weaknesses some countries obviously have
very strong ability to do certain things
and other countries have a different
singapore is never going to be an
agricultural giant
um it's never going to do but it's it
has very strong financial infrastructure
so i think
each country should not try and
replicate
everything but see where they have the
niche we have a lot more economic
activities
we have
a lot more common problems
that we have to deal with and and
technology will basically blur the the
boundaries across across countries so we
have to think more in terms of creating
win-win opportunities in in our asean
integration framework to promote growth
and to promote sustainable prosperity
for us in citizens i think asean will be
much more careful
and pragmatic so there'll be controlled
flows of labor and already if i'm not
mistaken millions of indonesians work in
malaysia singapore has got 1.7 million
foreigners working in the small island
city state
of singapore thailand gets a lot of
workers from myanmar coming in so there
is there is movement of labor but there
will never be a kind of the kind of
freedom of movement that you have for
example with the european union my dream
for us young is that it will continue to
stay together
and not break apart
as a result of u.s china rivalry because
there's one thing that keeps me awake at
night
it's worrying about how asean will
survive
this
incredibly intense u.s china rivalry
that is coming in the next 10 to 20
years
from source to ocean the mekong river
flows for more than 4 000 kilometers the
main artery that for centuries connected
this part of the world but times are
changing fast massive infrastructure
projects and the digital revolution are
creating a whole new future
[Music]
million people a combined economy the
size of india's
asean is an emerging market powerhouse
and within asean there lies a growth
giant it's called indonesia we are still
like behind just like india we are maybe
the two largest economy that if we make
a progress that will make a lot of
difference globally seventeen thousand
islands the largest muslim population on
earth targeting connectivity and
inclusion indonesia is a macrocosm of
what asean could be without borders
indonesia has to play the the leadership
role to make asean really strong and
make the asean centrality a reality
indonesia is home to an e-commerce
revolution and its president has plans
to create 100 million new jobs forging a
path to asean the next generation hello
welcome to jakarta the capital of
indonesia a country of 270 million
people at the very forefront of asean
its economy accounts for more than a
third of the block's gdp and it is on
track to become the world's fourth
largest economy by 2050.
i think more or less on and off
throughout the course of the history of
asean indonesia has played a leadership
role and as the biggest country
it does need to play what you call a
neutral role so that
its neighbors do not feel threatened
but i think in the in the forthcoming
next five ten years we do need to have a
stronger leadership role from indonesia
to make asean really strong and make the
asean centrality a reality
president jokowi has has a very
ambitious target on expanding financial
inclusion we have a program which is
consists of financial literacy education
but also in creating
digital banking
the brands of the banking or financial
services through the digital economy
which is i think it's now moving very
fast in india with that i think
technology is going to be one of the
solution but education and inclusion
which is based on literacy i think it's
going to be very critical
connectivity in the past always physical
but connectivity now through digital
indonesia
i think one of the most country the
advancing and using
technology in the telecommunication in
the register we can vitalize those
and reaching out
and you know integrating the economic
connectivity that's why we are
you know accelerating our development of
the payment system within the e-commerce
to increase the financial inc inclusion
and this is i think the a lot of
opportunity for indonesia to also
do uh you know reach out the sme as well
as the unbanked
to understand indonesia you have to
understand its remoteness a vast
archipelago spanning the distance from
new york to alaska the country plans to
spend 350 billion dollars over the next
five years building roads bridges and
power plants to link some of its 17 000
islands
president jokowi widodo has already made
significant progress a similar spend
during his first five-year term saw
highways pop up across the country
and jakarta's mess rapid transit system
now operational is a symbol of that
endeavor
the capital also has a new airport and
low budget airlines that are linking the
major cities
asean's only trillion dollar economy has
been growing at around 5
a year
not just about the physical connectivity
obviously but there's a whole range of
issues there you know about data flows
about payments about taxation about
privacy about security
and about talent i would say you know if
if we could actually address that fourth
freedom which is movement of
professional uh
workers if we could just focus actually
on on digital that that might actually
help a lot you know as as a beginning to
to have a wider professional movement
and it would help asean and if asean
became one market in the digital and
data flow sense i think we can we can
give
china competition actually there are so
many reform really required
for the asean country to be able to
design and
develop deepening financial
sector or financial system
then also creating an instrument which
is based on their local currency with
that you are not going to be affected
mostly by the external or regional
factors so you are more or less in
charge for your own economic development
financial inclusion is quite a key focus
for the region but financial literacy
is still quite low across the region how
challenging is that and how do you bring
everybody on board well indonesia is one
of the cases in which the financial
inclusion we are still like behind just
like india we are maybe the two largest
economy that if we make a progress that
will make a lot of difference globally
asean's role in the global economy is a
mathematical inevitability we're now
already a
three trillion dollar per year plus
economy growing at more than five
percent per year so 14 years from now
we're gonna go to being a
six to seven trillion dollar per year
economy out of a uh roughly 100 trillion
dollar per year world economy so we're a
significant chunk of the global economy
now and are only going to increase our
footprint
uh
14 and 18 years from now
and with size comes skill and influence
but asean has often been criticized for
being unable to empower change because
of what's been called its soft consensus
approach
in the increased uncertainty that we are
facing in the world it we need to be
stronger as asean and as asean in the
wider east asia region because i really
think that's the answer uh to the
greater uncertainty that we are facing
in the with multilateralism it should be
able to play a role uh as what we call a
middle power right because you've got
china you've got us as the big g2
countries the big elephants which are uh
when they are fighting or when when
they're in good friends we always we
will always have issues so we need to be
balanced be balancing it with japan with
korea and asean as a whole is is a
middle power
where do you think austin will be in 10
years what's the vision for asean for
you
well
there is a momentum if you look at the
global economy this is the only region
who continue vibrant and performing well
on the economy both in terms of the
policy
the burden as well as pragmatic as well
as there is a competition which is
healthy meaning that you are in a region
in which if you only grow by five
percent you are considered not
performing
the famous
saying which i believe is african in
origin
if you want to go fast go alone if you
want to go far go together
there is a lot to be said for
a large amount of consensus
but the beauty of asean is that it's
flexible so there's a lot of policy
space for
individual countries or
sub-regions to do what they think is
best
without having to conform to a straight
jacket of an asean-wide
policy
indonesia's president has promised to
create a hundred million jobs to reboot
the workforce with new skills for the
fourth industrial revolution
this is asean the next generation
when you travel around austria and you
see lots of young people the average age
of its population is just 29 years old
compare that to their leaders at 70 and
you get the idea of the leadership gap
tom when you take a look at southeast
asia at asean what excites you the most
when you look into the next 10 years
i would have to say it's the
next generation of young leaders in
politics in business like e-commerce
and the digital economy there's a next
generation of young political leaders
young business leaders young
leaders in the arts
media entertainment
fashions culinary civil society waiting
in the wings
and that's
what you're going to see across
southeast asia across asean
8 to 12 years from now and as we know
eight years 12 years goes by in the snap
of a finger but what will the new
leaders bring how will they
shape the face of asean going forward
there will be more of a southeast asian
identity uh eight or twelve years from
now versus a indonesian identity a thai
identity a filipino identity
we're going to see the emergence of a
southeast asian or asean
identity i think young people even
though they don't really think asean
asean is the way we we think about asean
in a way they are already aseanized
there's a identification of being part
of a region and and i think the youth is
the future of of of the region each of
us have our own national identities but
we also identify ourselves as being part
of this southeast asia region i think
because of travel because of
connectivity with the budget airline and
visas and
digital information we are connected you
know there's a digital
connectivity
that has boosted the information that
young people have about each other
president jokowi has plans for what he
says will be 100 million new jobs over
the next five years and while asean's
biggest economy has been growing fast
many young people are still finding it
hard to get work
so the focus is now shifting from
traditional industries to education for
the fourth industrial revolution with
the digital technology everybody can
become an entrepreneur even in this case
in one of the cases like bukalapak in
indonesia the entrepreneur can be as
young as just the primary school
which they actually have the hobby and
then they just put it online and that's
become closer to the market
the demand is there so i think
technology is going to provide more
opportunity for the sme indonesia
as well as on in asean and the world
that they can have an access
of market in a more efficient cheap
and effective way the problem maybe in
this case is how you are going to
understand this the ecosystem of this
digital economy so that everybody get
the fair share this is one of the most
challenging policy discussion at this
moment understanding the technology and
digital economy
in
creating job creating access creating
new opportunities
in indonesia a number of programs
already enhancing
the financial inclusion
first we already supporting the transfer
of social program of the government
through electronification
last year we already aimed
more than 15 million families
we are aiming 24 million all of them
through electronication
we also
do electronification of mode of
transportation
government of operation
so this reads out the unbanked that's
why indonesia finance inclusion jumped
from 40 percent now 60 percent and then
we are having 70 percent of financial
inclusion in indonesia
it of course there's a lot of
nervousness the labor flows are always
very sensitive and and it's a question
of how do you deal with the unskilled
labor how do you deal with the skilled
labor
unskilled labor will will continue to be
sensitive and probably that's better
dealt with and it is already being dealt
with bilaterally anyway but i think if
we could focus on the skilled labor
as well as the possibility for training
and education you know because i think
that's if we're going to be
going to the next stage
of of each of our countries development
as well as the future of economic
integration i think we have to it is
timely that we we address uh that that
particular component of of the economic
integration
financial inclusion and connectivity has
been the big story in indonesia and
here's why
according to the oecd smes account for
nearly 97 of domestic employment and 56
of total investment
grow them connect them nurture them and
the economy booms almost 70 percent of
indonesian adults have mobile phones sme
is the one who enjoy
this digital economy and industrial 4.0
in terms of their ability to access
market in the most efficient and cheap
way for example we have the gojek and
gopay and they now connecting at that
time they start with the 500
000 and i think maybe now close to a
million they are expanding to all cities
in indonesia
meaning that those
merchandise as well as sme which in in
the past they cannot access or closer to
the market because of logistical
information asymmetric they are now
actually become
the player who enjoy the benefit
in the past we can find supporting the
economy and sme on
upgrading their capacity of enterprises
and we done that
in indonesia we do a lot of things to
support the enterprise the sme but with
the digital economic finance
the startup
artists raised
on
accelerating the sme development there
is one story in unisa for example in the
past one sme they are selling a product
in the street but through the you know
e-commerce they are now already
exporting the future is the
technological revolution what it means
is that what we call the fifth freedom
you know the four freedoms which are
already in the asean economic community
is
a free trade in goods services
investment and people the fifth freedom
is data data flows right so
if asean is to to become a meaningful
economic integration region then we have
to address data flows the whole
rationale of asean has been this is a
training ground for us to
connect with each other with neighbors
as a practice before we
open up more globally so i i think i
still think that rationale is is very
important
and also very important to asean are the
indonesian unicorns
i think that we're only scraping the
surface of how big gojek could actually
be because our mission is really our
addressable market is the entire middle
class spend of the of uh southeast asia
next up the billion dollar companies
connecting asean the next generation
indonesia is home to southeast asian
unicorns takopedia traveloka gojek three
companies making a fortune connecting
the country into a central e-commerce
part the internet and mobile phones are
giving tens of millions of smes and
hundreds and millions of people access
to markets and finance
indonesia has more than 75 million
motorcycles so the idea to ride share on
them through jakarta's notorious traffic
was good good enough for gojek to now be
valued at 10 billion
gojek's influence on asean is huge
because it's not just ride sharing it's
also logistics food and fintech and it's
expanding fast we're already at about 30
35 of the two-wheeler market in vietnam
already after only like two three months
um which is incredible we were shocked
to see the uptake um so quickly um so
some of it will be up but a lot of it
will also be to expanding new verticals
and further increasing the penetration
of our services in indonesia which is
the largest market uh where we are the
market leader as you can see from our
shareholders where you've got google
you've got tencent you've got jd you've
got gic tamasek and and a variety of
other uh
heavy hitter financial institutions you
you really see in maituan as well you
really see the world's best at all the
key verticals that we are trying to uh
execute on in order to create this you
know the first in the world of a kind of
super app that actually encompasses all
your daily transactional needs
technology is going to also facilitating
this integration even more if you if you
see the unicorn and digital economy in
asia they are becoming one of the factor
that's creating this kind of integrity
integration faster you you talk about
grab group go jack you talk about
trafaluka these are all is already
playing at the
regional level and they become the
catalytic for the asean economy to
integrate even further the saturation
point of the consumers
versus say china
is still very small there's still so
much more to grow across transport
across food delivery cross payments
across logistics across digital goods
and so i think that that that we're only
scraping the surface of how big goja
could actually be because our mission is
really our addressable market is the
entire middle class spend of the of uh
southeast asia happily for us
president jokowi is also extremely
attuned to the millennials the gen zed
uh the next generation in the televised
presidential debates
he
raised things like esports and mobile
legends tournaments right and also
e-commerce and digital economy and
unicorns
i'm optimistic that that the aspirations
of the millennials gen zed
will will
come much more to fruition
in the hands of the
next generation leadership across asean
china is asean's largest trading partner
and has been for the past 10 years how
it plots a course between beijing and
washington given the current trade
difficulties is just one of many foreign
policy challenges the south china seas
issue pulling us apart
tpp splitting us down the middle but
somehow asean has been able to to to be
resilient and maintain its its process
and progress even though in some years
you could say it was slow uh but i think
there's always an effort to to say okay
what's what's the next challenge that we
have
you know we literally sit at the
crossroads
of
global trade 90 percent of the oil and
gas from the middle east heading to the
far east passes through indonesia
the states of malacca it's made us very
open to international
traffic if you will trade tourism
investment
and has also made us extremely tolerant
of diversity
of
cultures from around the world if you
talk about the 10 years from now you
have to see the dynamic of the asean
plus that is japan south korea or even
china in this case we have asean plus
three what is the dynamic of all this
country in east asia have
the influence on the acceleration of the
integration or even
it could be also slower
the integration because you have the
temptation to actually each country
to connect with all those players rather
than within the asean i'm i guess a half
a full glass person i'm optimistic that
asean uh will will continue to be
resilient and will
hopefully hopefully the the crisis in
the global trading system and
multilateralism should be a good uh
warning sign or opportunity let's look
at it as a positive it's an opportunity
for asean
to become stronger again
to to become
the balance here uh in in this
increasingly multipolar world and to
have a strong regional
presence to be able to have a voice
in what's happening in this very
uncertain
multilateral as well as
regional
uncertainties what do you expect to be
the biggest change we would see in asean
it's potentially unlike anything you've
ever seen because
it's happening
just
when
industry 4.0
cloud computing artificial intelligence
and all these next generation
technologies are taking off and i think
the people of southeast asia of asean
have proven to be uniquely gadget
friendly
right uniquely social media friendly
arguably
more so than any other region these
fishermen spend up to three months at
sea returning with a catch worth about
seventy thousand dollars
traditional businesses like these have
been the lifeblood of indonesia but
generational change is coming a new
future
the shimmering skyline of singapore home
to asean's financial hub and one of the
most expensive cities in the world
singapore is a place where private
enterprise meets money frankly a large
part of the asean story is driven by
private enterprise people sometimes say
you know asean grows at night when the
governments are asleep singaporean banks
arranged for up to 60 percent of all
project related finance in asean the
private sector wants something clearly
but from the public sector viewpoint and
from a country viewpoint you want
certain things for your people so you
must make sure that there is that right
match if we can combine the two both
public sector engagement and private
then you start to harness
the kind of balance sheets necessary to
make these projects happen striking a
balance on infrastructure is one of the
great challenges confronting asean the
next generation
hello i'm haslander amin in singapore a
country of just under six million people
accounting for less than one percent of
asean's population but about 12 percent
of its combined gdp singapore is a
financial and infrastructure hub of
southeast asia
nowhere else in the region is there
anything quite like singapore a small
island connected to the world by the
region's biggest airport and to global
trade by the world's second biggest
container port a smart city with highly
advanced financial markets education and
expertise the truth is asean has
countries in indochina who are small and
relatively less developed and on the
other end of the spectrum you have
countries like singapore who are first
world countries
so the two completely different parts of
the spectrum
and to think of a single prism and say
this is one market or one set of buyer
behavior or one set of opportunity
is not obvious when we talk to investors
around the world and ask them would they
invest in asean
the real response is you know my
decision
to invest in indochina would be very
different from my decision to invest in
thailand would be different from my
decision to invest in singapore this is
just the reality
dbs is southeast asia's biggest bank
more than half of its business is done
in singapore with half of its revenue
coming from institutional banking
frankly a large part of the asean story
is driven by private enterprise people
sometimes say you know asean grows at
night when the governments are asleep
and
that's uh i think for my money the
private sector will be
uh at the forefront a large of a large
part of the integration the businesses
which are going and beginning to
collaborate across borders and is the
consumer who's beginning to you know
vote with his or her feet so i think it
would be a story driven by the private
sector and by the individuals uh and
will take the government sector and the
public sector along so to a large extent
i think you know most governments have
the same goal they want to to make their
population more happy and they want and
to do this they need the right
infrastructure so of course there's
different deaf different countries
different approaches some countries are
depending a lot on the private sector
some others are more depending on their
state-owned enterprises i'm very much in
favor of ppp structures we have bidded
in ppp
investment opportunities in the
philippines and i'm a great believer
that private sector engagement
particularly with the balance sheets of
private companies now growing becoming
stronger in emerging markets like ours
there is an accountability and a
seriousness of intent that comes with
the private sector engagement in
traditionally public funded projects the
key thing is to look at it from the eyes
of private sector
they they won't mobilize their capital
unless they think it's financially
viable they're going to get a decent
rate of return on it and once you look
at it through that lens then you have to
understand that it needs to be
structured properly
and also the framework
and the regulations the investment
environment is is key the asian
development bank estimates asya needs to
spend 3.1 trillion dollars over the next
10 years to meet its infrastructure
needs singapore has set up what's
effectively a one-stop shop called
infrastructure asia
[Music]
capacity building uh in in countries is
also important because
if there is a project and there is a
proposal for how to structure it the the
civil servants or the the people within
the country who are assessing the
project must have the capability and the
ability to assess it well because it's
not just about having the project right
you also want returns for your people
you want employment you want a
capability transfer know-how transfer
and of course you want the benefits that
come from the project you obviously have
to have a collaboration between the two
because the public sector and public
policy obviously has to be informed uh
around and by the not just from a policy
standpoint from an infrastructure
standpoint so i think the public sector
has a role to play if you want to build
engines or payment rails i think the
public sector has a road to play if you
want to create
policies around capital markets
harmonization the public sector has a
road to play so i think this
participation is required but i do think
in many cases the private sector will
take the lead i think singapore is the
role model for
a lot of countries within asia
perhaps not only in asia but also to the
rest of the world in terms of the
forward-looking and making sure that
the public sector's policy is
truly in line with the trend
within the
private and the world
economy where it's going
science cement group is one of
thailand's biggest conglomerates an
infrastructure company that's been doing
business with countries in what is now
asean for more than 100 years from the
window of its bangkok headquarters you
can see the main station that will
connect fast trains from singapore all
the way to china thailand is doing a lot
of the investment in the infrastructure
i can see that countries like vietnam of
course
indonesia doing a lot of investment in
the infrastructure what we're seeing is
that there's also the trend trying to
link the infrastructure between the
countries in asia
with china
so i think
the expectation is that the next 10
years
the story line in terms of the
investment
at least from the government standpoint
will be on the infrastructure
with a rising middle class with growth
rapid growth
countries are wanting to build cities
small cities big cities they need the
the
overall layout and plans for for the
cities how to put it all together
waste sanitation uh water uh telecoms
electrification these are some of the
the key ones that we have encountered in
our in our conversations with the
countries around singapore if we can
combine the two both public sector
engagement and private then you start to
harness
the kind of balance sheets necessary to
make these projects happen most asian
countries are quite a few years behind
where they should be on the
infrastructure side that's come from of
course a very positive thing the
tremendous growth that's taken place but
urbanization the massive urbanization
that's taken place in in manila in
jakarta in bangkok uh you know the big
asian cities
have really led to just the dearth of
the kind of forward-looking
infrastructure that's needed i think you
really need a very tailored approach for
every country you've got singapore where
we're sitting today which is of course
extremely developed totally different
challenges and opportunities compared to
myanmar or laos or cambodia so what
we've done we really adapted our our
approach and our strategy for each of
these countries looking at what they
need to develop and making sure that we
bring the right solutions
general electro installed the first
light bulb here in the philippines
130 years ago up next finding the right
kind of power to sustain asean the next
generation
you've got 65 million people so about 10
percent that don't have access to
electricity some countries have a
electrification rate of 30 percent
within asean there is a shift not just
towards connectivity and inclusion but
also towards sustainability in a region
where coal is king energy demand has
grown by more than 60 percent over the
past 15 years
[Music]
we've got 65 million people so about 10
that don't have access to electricity
some countries have a electrification
rate of 30
while of course singapore is 100
so power generation is definitely the
key piece
um that that needs to be grown
we are focusing on on that market we
have the advantage that we have a full
portfolio we have all the renewable
technologies wind solar
also energy storage now but of course
also the the thermal technologies in gas
and even even coal
so again every country has specific
situation they have specific resources
some have no resources so that they need
to input and we really need to look at
customized solutions for each of them
for countries in the region to reach
their potential the demand for power
needs to be met
what are the challenges in meeting that
demand the challenge now from what i see
is you know power has really come from
very traditional fossil based
fuels in the past and issues of climate
change and sustainability become big now
and rightly so in in southeast asia how
to balance those energy needs on one
hand with a
a higher cry for sustainable solutions
on the other is the challenge we're
lucky that the
the price differential and and the cost
effectiveness of renewable energy has
begun to come down tremendously in the
last five years and there's an
opportunity to start taking up the
percentage of renewable energy in the
energy equation
the ayala group is the oldest and one of
the biggest conglomerates in the
philippines its energy arm is working on
renewable projects worth around 1
billion dollars in the philippines
indonesia and vietnam and as a block
asean has set a target for renewables to
make up 23
of the power mix by 2025.
most governments have become far more
enlightened certainly in the philippines
there's a big move towards renewables
now the challenge for us in the private
sector is to start adjusting our
portfolios and start participating in
those areas
that's the challenge i think really
addressing energy needs but in a
renewable way and that's the challenge i
think governments face and private
sector groups face
you've always had a view
that you need to have a balanced outlook
on the whole agenda of sustainability
climate change is a big issue it will
has been the biggest issue in the next
10 15 years but it's like everything a
nuanced issue an extreme view would be
to say let's stop everything to do with
fossil fuel energy today the reality is
all over east asia the massive
requirement for energy over the next 10
15 years
and the reality is today there are no
alternatives to uh fossil fuel we have
the likes of dbs and the aiib saying
that they will not lend unless a project
is totally green and sustainable but is
it realistic
in a region
that's basically looking for cheap
source of power which is called and call
remains king yeah i think the world is
doing the right thing and financial
institutions are doing the right thing
moving
the equation uh towards a renewable
space and we ourselves in our own
portfolio
have set a goal of having fifty percent
i guess of our energy production in our
own portfolio to be renewable in the
long term um i do believe there's always
a balance uh i'm not an extremist in my
views uh uh i think we should have a
direction towards renewables
but there are cases depending on the
energy needs base load and the like
where fossil based solutions are still
the most efficient you've got to figure
how do you continue to support today's
generational needs while at the same
time recognizing that you can't keep
going down this path because this would
create a really dark future so we tried
to balance the two and so you know we
will figure out how we can start
calibrating down our thermal
energy financing obviously banks have an
important role to play and at the same
time we got to give people an
alternative so we're stepping up our
renewable financing we've been doing a
lot more solar we're doing a lot more
wind we're doing a lot more biofuel
biomass to be able to help finance the
alternatives
for the u.s giant at general electric
southeast asia represents a massive
growth opportunity its annual revenue
from the region has doubled to seven
billion dollars in eight years across
the region it employs 10 000 people i
think the main growth opportunity for
the future is having these countries
work even closer together i was in laos
last week and and laos in the in the
north is generating a lot of electricity
that is exported to vietnam and thailand
while in the south they are importing
from vietnam in thailand so from an
energy perspective the grid system is a
key to to have the electricity at the
right place and i think that's a lot of
that's where where the region could do
better in in generating more
relationships between the countries in
terms of the physical infrastructure but
what's key is inclusive growth inclusive
development for countries like indonesia
for instance where they have 17 000
islands a vast archipelago what do you
bring to the table to help bridge the
differences so i think in indonesia it's
an interesting case indonesia needs both
the the big power generation plants on
java or sumatra the densely populated
areas and then we have got smaller
systems more gas engine solutions that
we bring to the remote areas and we
recently actually did
bring a lot of electricity to remote
islands by bringing these most stand
mostly standalone solution trailer
mounted so very easy to install
and and that's been a great achievement
of course on the side of the indonesian
government to bring power to places
where there was no power before almost
every country has an infrastructure plan
that ranges from 100 billion to 300
billion
yet here we are still talking about the
death of infrastructure
in southeast asia why is that the case
if there's one action that needs to be
taken what would that be the growth has
been so tremendous
that everybody's generally playing
catch-up and
and you need that infrastructure to
basically prime and make that growth
sustainable for the long term so i'm
very much in favor of uh
planning ahead and overweighting
infrastructure particularly in major
economic centers
and that would be one way to keep that
economic growth going but i think
governments have to deal with a lot of
balancing i guess of political issues
social issues and the like and i can
understand why it doesn't always happen
perfectly
up next from hanoi to ho chi minh how
vietnam is embracing change
[Music]
the real value of fintech is it reduces
costs of everything frankly there's the
advantage of technology technology is
fundamentally deflationary so your cost
of customer access reduces the cost of
transacting the customers reduces the
ability to underwrite customers uh
improves
and if you assume that the cost burden
comes down then even lesser developed
countries can get greater financial
system penetration so i really think
there's only a positive i don't see a
negative at all i think all countries
that are now
they're trying to make an improvement in
terms of making it easier to do business
but also trying to make sure that at
least the law and regulation providing
the right incentive for the companies to
invest in those countries it's not easy
you know to operate in not only
different countries
but also in different tax law
regulations
and process so that's something that at
this point i would say is the most
biggest
challenges for us so i think the the
face of uh of asean in terms of the
smart cities so really the cities it
will get more modern i think cities are
going to adapt to what uh what the
cities need to be in the future so more
sustainable more environmentally
friendly
less traffic jams so there's still a lot
of work to be done in the region but i
think there's going to be drastic change
in in the way cities are operated and
especially the way cities are powered
over the next the years to come i think
ppp projects depending on the way
they're structured but if they address
real public
public sector needs particularly in
transportation in
basic infrastructure that brings people
more formally into the economy in an
easier way it becomes a very inclusive
component and affects people from all
walks of life particularly lower income
groups you take for example a major
transportation project in a major urban
city it's tough it's tough for people in
southeast asia to move around their
major cities
[Music]
the philippine economy is forecast to
grow by almost seven percent in 2019
making it the fastest growing among the
asean five and outside the region's
biggest economies vietnam is on a
similar course
[Music]
i have to say that i've now been
involved with vietnam for 20 odd years
and the shifts are quite clear
moving from a complete command and
control environment to letting the
market forces and private capital play a
role so i think the shift is tangible at
the same time they still have a long way
to go
because relative to many of the other
more market oriented economies in asean
vietnam
can still be a little more difficult
from a market standpoint to get things
done you're scaling up your investments
in renewables for example in vietnam why
vietnam why is it exciting they were
offering um interesting feed-in tariffs
for investors to come in within a tight
time frame so you look at that and you
say you know i could put my capital here
i could put my capital there if a
government is suddenly very welcoming to
you then of course capital starts to
move towards that
vietnam has been very welcoming to
specific projects in the renewable space
and it just so happened that in our
particular case we had built up
expertise a management team and the
financial ability to tackle those
projects at this point in time so we
said well why not you know part of asean
asean is an exciting place and vietnam
is being generous i guess with
with their investment offerings in that
space so we took advantage of it and
moved quickly in that direction the
major projects i think the
what's come first to my mind is the our
investment in the petrochemical complex
in the
southern part of vietnam
close to ho chi minh city
that's roughly about 5.4 billion u.s
dollars
right now we started the construction
already
the project progress is roughly about 10
percent
we do expect that it's going to take
another
three and a half four years before we
can start the commercialization
that is uh supposedly the first
petrochemical complex within vietnam
when you take a look at asean what do
you deem as the biggest challenge for
the region
well
let me start with the positive right
because
the challenges come from these are all
positive challenges because uh you know
the region's really been doing so well
right if you look at
global growth uh you know southeast asia
and asia in general is really been a
shining light and i think will continue
to be for a while so the challenge
really comes from how to make that
growth sustainable and predictable and
and
sort of you know continuing i guess over
the medium and long term
there's some fascinating trends taking
place urbanization is becoming massive
but with that come the challenges of the
infrastructure needs of of an urban
environment so that's a big challenge
and you can see it traveling through any
major city in southeast asia
[Music]
in aviation there's there's now about
1800 aircrafts that are flying around
asia over the next 10 years there will
be 2 200 additional coming onto the onto
the market so so more than doubling
power generation the same 260 megawatts
today gigawatt installed another 200
gigawatt to be ordered over the next 10
years and healthcare exactly the same
healthcare has had a very steady growth
over the last years about 10 percent
there's thousands of hospitals that are
planned new hospitals across the region
people are also more connected
you know i think partly because of the
technology that allow us to to be able
to move through
and
understand
the difference in terms of the culture
and language
better so i say that this is this is the
the most
advanced and improvement that i have
seen
between the countries within asia for
the last four to five years the one big
difference is uh the proliferation of
asean brands
and i think that's a
relatively new phenomena whether it's
airasia or whether it's grab or whether
it's gojek uh particularly in the
technology driven space you're beginning
to see asean brands go around the space
and we didn't see a lot of those before
so that has been a shift
the second shift is i think there is a
desire and slow step but steady steps to
integrating the markets
public policy and private enterprise
within borders and beyond power to the
people partnerships and shared
prosperity
they are the future of asean tech savvy
and on the move creating a whole new
consumer class it's now two steps you
swipe and you go and it's quick it's
fast it's gonna be intuitive more than a
third of asean's 640 million people are
aged between 15 and 34. we're one of the
biggest brands in the world for the
youth and millennial and what better
than one of the youngest populations in
the world creating opportunities driving
change i like to say if you can make it
in asean you probably can make it
anywhere leisure lifestyle e-commerce
and leadership nowadays fast forward
everybody's full of promise and passion
all this know-how from abroad they are
asean the next generation welcome to
bangkok capital of thailand asean's
second largest economy a country like
the rest of southeast asia that's
navigating an incredible rise in the
internet economy in a region that's
spinning its hopes on a new younger
consumer class
with an average age in asean of just 29
the millennials the youth are behind a
booming middle class that's set to top
400 million people by 2020
that's twice what it was just eight
years ago
i have to say the past 30 years have
changed so much like when i came here
and
me being a thai person that looks thai
and doesn't speak at like hardly any
time people just looked at me so weirdly
i was like the ugly duckling
nowadays fast forward everybody's full
of promise and passion all this know-how
from abroad we're seeing a lot of sea
turtles come back so meaning they're
from thailand from asia from all over
they go abroad and they're bringing back
all of their knowledge and their
know-how and just so much passion to us
i think technology will only accelerate
whatever you have currently
in a way that they make
things faster better and cheaper
so for indonesia or asean for that
matter you know you have young people
right and then you have hard working
people very social right and they want
to solve problems so technology will
only be positive in indonesia and also
asean so i like to say if you can make
it in asean you probably can make it
anywhere but not vice versa all of a
sudden you know instead of having to go
through traditional forms of building
out logistics networks or
telecommunications networks we're going
to see 5g for example being rolled out
very quickly in the region you're going
to see
huge amounts of digital consumption
happening right from the get-go without
that huge that long curve that comes
alongside with it so i think the the
critical period is really for the for
the next two or three years over here in
southeast asia and we're going to see
this massive upswing um in the next 10
to 15 years both in terms of consumption
both in terms of investment and i think
the development of the entire region
we're
in a place where we've got
a huge group of millennials coming back
um from where they've been you know
educated you know number one or getting
exposure in different countries but at
the same time we've seen um a
upscaling of
uh
generations of workers that were never
upskilled um we were in a generation of
people that were richer much richer than
we've ever been
rachel lau's father was the late
malaysian real estate and investment
tycoon lao bunan together with two
friends also from prominent families
she's building what she hopes will
become southeast asia's largest
independent investment fund forest
southeast asia is and will be the most
interesting market and the most
attractive market in the next 10 to 15
years because of a younger population
we've got a generation shift of mindsets
in terms of politics
we've got huge consumptions which again
we've never seen but also a highly
educated population that is migrating
over
again not just only southeast asia but
people moving over the south asian i
think that's something we forget about
it's not just the people on the ground
who are already here there's people who
actually want to move over
and with that you'll see more innovative
ideas coming into this part of the world
if you think about it in the last 60
years you know asean has made a lot of
progress in trade gdp like to the tune
of 20 to 30 times right
but this
improvement can be made accelerated with
technology
because
technology not only making faster better
cheaper for a lot of things that you do
but it does solve a lot of problems
faster better cheaper as well
so again i think when you look at
indonesia or asean the infrastructure
issues the payment issues the um
the hr issues uh the capability the
know-how those can be saved a lot by
technology we're investing in the talent
over here in southeast asia incredibly
important for us so we've just announced
for example our southeast asian
headquarters right here in singapore
we've also announced a fintech hub for
ourselves in malaysia so we've got right
from the get-go hundreds and hundreds of
people being trained but we're also
bringing talent from the valley talent
from our european headquarters over here
to get this whole cross-pollination of
uh different people so that's the
midterm plan really build up the talent
across um the entire region
tan min liang is a rising asean
entrepreneur a self-made billionaire
after the ipo of its gaming company
razer
born and educated in singapore based in
silicon valley he's targeting southeast
asia for the company's next growth spurt
definitely we see southeast asia as a
huge growth region for ourselves and for
the company
as i've mentioned you know the very
young population out here and very tech
savvy i'm hungry i think uh for um huge
amounts of consumption for entertainment
that's something for ourselves at razor
we think there's a huge opportunity for
ourselves and it's really finding the
right kind of product or service to
cater to the population the region i'd
say we're 10 years behind china in terms
of evolution in digital economy
but we're getting there much faster than
any of our predecessors were in china or
all the us or the european nations
coming into the digital economy so i
think we're in the beginning but we're
moving much faster than we've ever seen
any of the other economies moved and
here's a sense of how connected
southeast asia is the philippines leads
the world in time spent on social media
indonesia is number one in using mobile
phones for e-commerce and the ties leads
the pack when it comes to browsing the
net on their mobile phones
the way we've consumed or if we've used
internet is very on the go and it's very
mobile
so we're
a lot more
mobile and more on the move as opposed
to our previous generation
so how i see it has to be faster it has
to be more adaptive it has to be
intuitive in ways and so it's not you
know
five steps it's now two steps you swipe
and you go and it's quick it's fast um
it's gotta be intuitive i started
getting in tech at lazada before second
employee at lazada's 2011. the internet
penetration was like 20
in thailand alone today is probably like
70 or 80
the mobile penetration right now it's
like something ridiculous like a hundred
ten percent that means everybody has one
and a half phones each we didn't have
that 10 years ago that's all that just
happened 10 years ago nowadays my my
husband
he's from norway he lives in thailand he
doesn't speak a word tie
like zero time he'd get anywhere it's
not just normal taxi die he could
actually do business he could go talk to
lawyers he could go get new markets and
whatnot like there's just so much stuff
that's that's happened and that's just
bangkok
the size of southeast asia's internet
economy is expected to more than triple
over the next five years to a quarter of
a trillion dollars as penetration rates
continue to rise
welcome back for all the opportunities
the digital economy promises the young
asean has still to capitalize and
complete the journey because if it
doesn't the next generation risks
getting old before getting rich
internet penetration rates may be
growing and in some asean countries the
percentage of people connected is quite
high but most of asean still lags behind
the developed world in indonesia for
example while those who have it use it
heavily around 40 of the population
don't have access at all and then
there's health and education is there a
risk that indonesia could grow old
before it gets rich yeah i think that's
basically what a lot of people are
saying if you're not careful you will be
trapped as a middle-income country so
all this nice prediction about indonesia
being number five number 7 in 20 to 30
years will be a fantasy
so
now and i think president jokowi is
focusing on that we should focus on
the needy greedies
the process
but also the soft infrastructure you
know people say demography is the key to
success but i think demography will be
also the challenge to succeed if you
don't you know fuel them with the right
education the right attitude
anindia bhakri is the ceo of bhakri and
brothers an indonesian investment
company that oversees the family empire
with interests in everything from mining
to telecommunications
inclusion to materialize you need
equitable education
how do you go about getting there after
the infrastructure which is basically
the hard infrastructure that we see
the bridges the ports the roads i think
the next soft infrastructure will be
you know health and education but the
question is what kind of education will
be fit for the quote-unquote
industrialization 4.0 i think that's the
question
because you know not only we need to uh
have good students but we also need uh
you know to train the trainers i just
came from a meeting where we were
talking about how do you bring education
across to the masses right um and i
think that is definitely one of the
things that the millennials over here
are obsessed with because it's not just
about work life
balance it's about work live
play and learn and i think the learning
bit is something that it's not just
coming from top down but bottoms up too
you're seeing a lot of the millennials
the the youth saying
i want to be at places where i can learn
i want to be at places where i can play
you know at the same time i just met up
with um
three startups today all education and
basically they're not waiting around for
the reforms of the thailand ministry of
education anymore uh this is the same
issue in indonesia same issue in the
philippines i mean it's a pretty much
same issue all over southeast asia and
basically what they're doing is they're
cutting out you know the regulations and
basically going back to what do you
actually need to survive is it a college
degree
is it university
not everybody's going to be a mark
zuckerberg right so that's like genius
beyond recognition but there are like
key skills that you could acquire for
yourself to actually make a living
shaman who co-founded her own successful
e-commerce site for women in 2012
now advises the venture capital firm
gobi partners on tech startups in
southeast asia i mean people ask me all
the time
are we going to see a unicorn
well you know thailand doesn't even have
good grants to incorporate
a company here in thailand itself so all
of us
startups i you know just flock to
singapore
because of the grants like you said
right so temasek or you know all the
spring and all the different initiatives
they have
thailand doesn't really have too many of
those
um and because of that the first unicorn
is going to be a singapore incorporated
thai company the conversation today when
it comes to startups is between silicon
valley as well as shin chin do you
envision a time in southeast asia could
be a big part of it it's happening right
now you know um already you are seeing
tech unicorns come out from this side of
the world you're myself but not to the
extent that we're seeing in china for
instance well i think you'll probably
see that coming a long ways in the next
couple of years i think you know you're
seeing a lot more new tech startups come
over
on the side of the world
you know myself i think you know we're
coming back from the valley to see what
else we can do to invest over here we
are investing in companies over here
startups over here so you know i do see
huge amounts of opportunity right here
in southeast asia and i think it's going
to be a massive massive opportunity
we've talked about how silicon valley
could be overtaken by shin chin
could southeast asia be a contender in
that race at some point in time oh i'd
say yes so
you know i've spoken to some guys and
they're actually moving some of their
startups from the us to vietnam
one of the reasons why is because you
get very skilled labor for a quarter of
the price and so cost is a big factor
and if we're more competitive in this
part of the world and we've got highly
skilled labor it
i don't see why not what could hinder
the development
politics probably i mean we've got to
figure out how to
deal with politics how do we be more
efficient in um
foreign workers movement and so as
southeast asia alone we're not an
integrated economy the way europe is an
integrated economy in terms of free
movement of labor and it's not great in
terms of
currencies you know there's highly
volatile currencies that can't really
decide where they need to be it's it's
really politics which then kind of
decides the rest of the landscape for
southeast asia the young the millennials
increasingly becoming a problem for
governments wanting to meet their
aspirations what are some of the
challenges
well i think you know some of the
governments see them as a problem some
of the governments see them as an
opportunity well the thing about the
young the millennials they're not
getting their news or or information
from traditional sources anymore you
know these are guys that you know um
they don't go to the movies so much they
don't uh read the newspapers they don't
watch tv some of them don't even have a
tv right so literally what are they
doing they're entertaining themselves
playing games they're they're very
comfortable using virtual credits from
us for that matter
over and above you know they're learning
information from social media and things
like that so many of the governments
today they're learning how to re-engage
with them in terms of contribution from
the millennials
how would you quantify that and in what
areas um this is an interesting question
right so um i've had this conversation
with a lot of people how malaysia is
doing in his economy given the new
political um regime
i've said it's doing better than it's
ever done which is at odds with pretty
much every economist
on the street
and the reason is pretty simple when i
go to
a boba tea shop
it's packed the line's two hours wait uh
when i go to my nails a lot you know
it's a it's it's a it's a five hour wait
when first quarter gdp came out from
malaysia this year and we're talking
just about malaysia uh because i'm
assaulting malaysia
we've seen first quarter beat estimate
by perfect consumption and it's not
infrastructure-led it's not
you know public utilities it's all
private consumption so in terms of
spending you know there's a niche
markets which we have neglected and this
is the millennial spending on
consumption goods
up next
seizing a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
what the future looks like through the
eyes of asean the next generation
i believe the asean integration has
gone on as good as it could be
because we have to be realistic
the 10 countries within asean are at
different levels of economic maturity
so it is difficult to pull them together
and say let us have one rule that is a
one tariff
it's not possible to do that us isn't
going to be a big reason because when
you look at the growth when you look at
the stability when you look at the
demographic of people
these are all the factors that certainly
support the growth in this area and when
you look at the
diversity
of the economy in the region thailand
are strong in one way malaysia singapore
vietnam indonesia philippine lao
cambodia myanmar wow you will see a lot
of things that will come out of this
region
the young population in cambodia
they are young very energetic and dry
for education
and i think
[Music]
moving to this um digitized or
industrialized
economy like our government is talking
about
e-economy so we need to build a capacity
their skill
that's why we have to reform a lot of
structural reform in the education
department and in the way how the
industrial in cambodia is going to be
there's always that risk that some
people get left behind
but
i think if we all
look at the goals together i think we
will move towards uh
towards more inclusive growth for
everyone you have to remember i think
all of us are realized that when the
tide rises all boats rise
so
we have to help each other
achieve that
no one really knows what asean will look
like in 10 15 or 20 years but with
foundations in place the outlook is good
the challenge now is for the region's
leaders to take the next step does the
current leadership in southeast asia
reflect the aspirations of the next
generation
um
i don't know
[Laughter]
again you've got you know an average 70
year old a cohort of politicians and
you've got an average 29 year old
citizens
um
what they've been seeing or done in the
past
i admire
wholeheartedly
but i think there's been a lot of issues
that they haven't addressed such as
um
to your point activatable education what
is equitable and what is education and
an education to a lot of people mean
different things
the ways that we've
made a livelihood
we so in malaysia i've had this
conversation with a government official
multiple times
i said invest in the tech economy
because by investing in a digital
economy you'll be able to create more
jobs than you ever thought you would
there's no questioning asean's progress
it's been good an average gdp growth
rate across the 10 countries are more
than 5
every year for 10 years
a rising consumer class better wages
more jobs more infrastructure booming
e-commerce bad has been from a
relatively low base
how do i envision southeast asia to be
would be
you know
very basic things you know have great
infrastructure but have great software
that supports the infrastructure
have great regulatory systems
political systems
we stem out corruption and bribery all
together
we have greater governance there's more
accountability to the people and
stakeholders involved all the country as
a whole and how do we move forward from
you know being
playing
politics and and making politics about
personal ideals right 10 years down the
road 20 years down the road how will
asean look like
i think asean will be more confident
will be much more more confident because
the numbers will show right the numbers
is saying whether 10 years or 20 years
asean will be about 13 trillion u.s
dollar
economy 13 trillion is about uk
france and germany combined
so when you have that kind of size you
are you're confident right and we hope
indonesia as the owner of 40 of the
market share today
can grow along with it i believe that in
the next 10 15 years you're going to see
a massive explosion of the youth coming
from southeast asia traveling outside of
southeast asia
a lot more startups coming within
southeast asia and your dream for asean
10 years down the road i would love a
common market you know throughout asean
i think it's important that asean
realizes that we are a huge market for
ourselves and unity is always important
having a common market i think that's
something i would love to see
i would love to see over and above um
plurality of companies moving across
asean and you know dealing within asean
not just as a common market but but
viewing
the people in asean as a common people
but on inclusion sustainability and
connectivity the last mile may yet prove
to be the biggest challenge i feel that
in terms of the hustle and the drive and
the passion to try to solve again the
same mutual problems that we have which
is poverty education you know
sanitation um a lot of getting retail
access to the the provinces we have the
same kind of fintech you know being able
to have um cheaper car sources of
finance being able to pay your loans on
time we do all
have the same obstacles which means we
all are trying to solve the same
problems so in terms of identity i think
i think we're all kind of the same
people
but we have our own little like
what's the word for it twerks
[Music]
you know it's us you know and this is
our legacy it's not our parents it's not
grandparents that we're saying you know
there's too many unbanked population
there's too many things that the current
financial institutions are not
addressing so how do we address it from
a millennial standpoint from a you know
a younger southeast asian standpoint and
and to southeast asia if 90 if the
average age is 29 years old
then we are southeast asia you know it's
not the 60 year olds or the 70 year old
politicians who are in place right now
right it's us it's the new generation
coming up
for asean the future is here led by a
dynamic young population
riding the tide of rapid change a once
in a lifetime opportunity thanks for
watching asean the next generation
[Music]